Giuseppe Vecchio Lottie is an
anthropologist he was digging in the
graveyard at Bhatia put savetti in the
summer of 2012 when he got a surprise
virgil Oddie's team had found a trench
covered with a thick layer of lime he
knew that people tossed lime into graves
to prevent infection in ancient times
these graves looked like some they'd
seen from the Middle Ages from the time
of the Black Death they found five
bodies encased in lime it began to look
like an epidemic the team thought they'd
found a mass grave full of plague
victims so the scientists decided let's
dig them up the lime had sealed the
bodies like a cast or a cement blanket
cracking it open was tough the team used
drills picks trowels it was very dusty
work the students felt like they were
eating lime but everybody was in a good
mood they were excited to see what they
would dig up they cracked open little
windows so they could see the skeletons
below
they used brushes and dental tools to
carefully remove the dirt one body had
its arms over its head others were lying
on their sides these were the first
signs that the skeletons were different
their positions were odd it suggested
they'd been buried in a hurry it looked
like their families didn't have time to
bury them properly or even put their
arms over their chests this epidemic
must have killed a lot of people fast
one woman had been buried in a shroud or
some kind of bag the lime on her
skeleton was very thick like a shell
when the team finally opened it they
realized that this was an anthropologist
dream it was a perfect skeleton almost
every bone was intact her bones were
thin and fragile her teeth were very
worn that suggested she must have been
in her 50s or maybe her 60s and the
scientists could tell she'd had children
they knew by looking at her pelvis
she was probably somebody's grandmother
her skeleton left impressions in the
soft dirt the scientists could see
traces of her ear
her fingers the shroud when the team
lifted her skull
they found a gold earring it was the
kind of earring women wore to church so
the team decided to call her the lady
with the gold earring
but that earring it threw a wrench into
the theory that she died in the Middle
Ages it clearly came from the 1800s and
it turned out these bodies had actually
been buried around 1850 but the plague
struck in medieval times so what did the
lady with the gold earring die of the
researchers suspect cholera they call it
the blue death people turn blue because
they get so dehydrated color a swept
through Tuscany in 1855 sailors brought
it to the ports nearby then it spread
fast killing thousands to find out if
the lady died of cholera researchers
hope to get bacterial DNA from the soil
now you won't find any cholera DNA in
bone that's because it's a gut disease
so the team is scooping dirt from her
stomach area where the bacteria might
have settled after she was put in the
grave if geneticists can recover DNA
from cholera it should help them
understand why this disease was so
virulent in 19th century Italy it could
even help scientists design better drugs
and vaccines and that would all be
thanks to the lady with the gold earring
you